[Musique]
caroline ithurbide chaque semaine le
chroniqueur de nous raconter quelque
chose la thématique du soir c'est avec l
animateur télé partiriez-vous pas
commencé avec lequel surtout vous ne
partirez pas j'ai pas demandé à elsa py
partie rive alors là comme ça oui comme
ça n'en fait pas tout de suite posé vous
démotiver deux heures d'émission avec
tout ce que vous partagerez qu'une
invite vraiment je ne croule pas sous
les propositions
j'aimerais bien partir avec nikos
visiter les cyclades comme bien partir
avec des gens qui savent où ils vont et
puis avec qui vous ne partiriez
absolument pas vouloir avec gilbert
gress voilà
[Applaudissements]
retenez bien regarder ce qu'il revienne
sous les parades son émission
[Rires]
est-ce bon bus bondés l'onu dit calme le
jour mais là où vous lui on a le droit
de dire ce qu'on veut il a raison merci
caroline en tout cas parce que le
créateur voit enfin que sont plus les
mis à l'honneur comment ça va c'est très
bien ça vous plairait bien porter ces
trolls alors vous êtes sympas ce soir
non mais surtout on sait pas qu'un peu
de vous
[Applaudissements]
il reste parce que la communion tiers
est magnifique ce hold you really there
est très attaché aux tenues
vestimentaires adore ça et attendez vous
allez voir leur viol a ring on arrive à
la dentellière dans quelques-uns avec
qui vous partez en vacances
bah moi j'avais dit nikos aussi aux noms
et aux bailleurs mais j'ai pas honte
d'être de grands sacs est là parce
qu'elle est beaucoup trop mignonne me
suis tendu je suis ni cause si vous
acceptez les deux joueurs quand même
s'en empare ensemble soit sinon je
change
je me permets une petite infidélité et
je prends laurent delahousse à l'euro de
la houlette du coup tu me donne des
idées
excellent choix et je ne portais pas
avec je crois que je pars pas avec
patrick sébastien
[Applaudissements]
et toute la journée sympa au petit
déjeuner à la plage et mieux en
permanence alors comment va-t-elle a
vanté hier elle va très bien elle et
elle est le mystère on ne sait pas qui
se cache derrière cette femme comme un
kinder sauveteurs kinder ont fini par le
démonter le savoir que l' on ne peut pas
le faire alors alors avec qui je
partirai exactement alors sur mon moteur
de recherche génie animateur télé qui
aime jouer au poker aime jouer au tennis
et en même temps qui me laisse du temps
pour pouvoir lire j'ai trouvé cyril
hanouna
alors vous vous avez vraiment envie d'
une ville jeune et on se remet à y aller
nos chaînes mais vous dire ou pas est
classée au tennis ou oui vous êtes
combien 15,3 à pas mal et vous ne partez
pas vu qui avec camille pourquoi est ce
qu'en fait il est trop kazan il m'a dit
qu'ils détestent et partir quand même
resté chez lui il déteste les avions il
déteste faire ses valises
salon goisses haut et moi j'adore partir
donc je pense qu'on voit là je pourrai
pas être compatible avec annie pour ses
vacances la bio merci nous avons le bien
brochet du jour là c'est notre copain
comment il va il va très bien
aujourd'hui maxime
bd avec une part en vacances avec jean
pierre foucault a cédé sacrée soirée
avec lui surtout il a plongé dans les
années dans les piscines de
d'intervilles parce que il a surfé sur
cette activité pendant tout l'été quand
j'étais gosse et surtout je crois qu'il
vit dans les alentours de marseille à
l'aller
ouais car ils vous voitures de
collection en décapotable 4l et une
petite promenade un petit tour d'année
là c'est du grand n'importe quoi qu'est
ce que vous allez faire est ce que vous
croyez que jean pierre foucault envie de
partir aux mains dans ce cas nul
il annule tous dessus mais j'ai envie et
avec qui vous ne voulez pas parti avec
georges pernoud ce bon vieux loup de mer
parce que j'ai le maire s'est un peu
compréhensible à des frais faudrait que
je fasse qu'un sur deux
paco rabanne est de retour je vais lire
je mets à durban
voilà je vois l'avenir voilà douze mois
regardez je penserai à la photo que j'ai
préparé moi je pars avec vous à mon
passé grand chose mais quelle faille non
mais bastien d'abord pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que vous êtes très
sympathique et c'est vrai vous êtes
assez drôle je suis en train de de
promouvoir mon nouveau spectacle qui
démarre à 7 heures un spectacle assez
drôle j'ai par des premières vous voilà
et puis et puis j'ai vu votre femme
oui quand même très très bien c'est
drôle aussi voilà donc et puis surtout
c'est que si j'essaie je veux faire un
barbecue d'accord ok donc vous venez de
le croire face un barbecue pendant que
vous faites ma femme on doit céder
franchement ici aussi les choses votre
copain il a regardé et monsieur quand ça
va
et puis pour tout le reste c'est le
meilleur je le trouve sympa gentil les
droits humains généreux j'adore c'est
pas le concours du meilleur animateur ce
avec qui on a envie de partir on a pour
effet avec qui je pars passé avec arthur
partage rien nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs vous avez il vous faut ré
découvrir pas mal de choses ordures rien
leur album aux capus n'a pu elle est
émue 1 parce que c'était la dernière de
camille elle s'est régalée là bas c'est
vrai oui bah trop d'émotion cette
semaine entre mon départ tous font
passer les prochaines camille c'est fini
bao j'embrasse ses amis voilà j'ai passé
une super faisant à ses côtés alors avec
qui je partirai comme animateur et ben
justement j'y avais pas pensé mais
calmes et parce qu'on se rapproche un
peu il est très calmes amis et moi aussi
je suis très casanière et sinon
changement de génération thierry
ardisson et sa carrière me fascine et
j'aimerais trop tu me racontes pendant
les heures de passage lui faire plaisir
de partir en vacances et d'avoir
quelques côtés sur le matelas qui lui
pose des questions sur sa carrière
seulement sur sa carrière mais le
personnage martigues
voilà il ya eu un truc tout à l'heure
qui s'est passé dehors ils en pensent
quoi camille vous avez une grosse
frayeur zénith ou de la cabine et vous
vous étiez en train de vous préparer
vous étiez en train de découvrir les
juges rappellent que les chroniqueurs
arrive toujours sept à huit minutes à
voir c'est normal on est des pros mer
var et donc on a regardé ce qu'il s'est
passé j'étais devant parce que j'étais
là bien avant tout le monde regardait
ses moeurs maintenant découvrir le look
de capucine attention c'est parti qu'a
pu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment négrier parce qu'on lui refaire
le coup mais en fait c'est bien vous
aurez perdu votre cacher cet oriental et
au disque et qui sait bien caché c'est
une vraie phobie des clous et donc ça
aurait pas marche pourquoi je sais pas
c'est vrai c'est judiciaire et la même
terreur et doullens erreur je m'en tire
que vous étiez vous aussi à dormans un
bon et ont peur des clowns du cirque
périphérie et le temps des mets cloud et
surtout peur de vous aussi vous le
rendent bien comment ça va emilie lopez
je tiens à rappeler que quand une
émission est bonne c'est parce que je
suis bon et quand elle est mauvaise et
pasquet midi la mal préparés alors vu
qu'ils portent et bain avec mon grand
poteau lui la vraie castaldi dans le
temps il ya quelques mois on sait mais
pas trop non
et autant maintenant ils te plairait
mais moi non plus je pourrai pas que ça
qu'il faut des combattants des balises
un peu de smecta si vous portez avec lui
sinon vous le raconter j'ai su pour rire
j'aimerais bien même en plateau pas con
plateau d'ailleurs c'est qu'ils pèsent
beaucoup aimé ça mais je suis et jours
maintenant mais c'est vrai excuse moi
mais tu pètes bouquet la dépilation pas
la dernière
d'ailleurs allez dans le love qui est
présenté ce n'était pas un jacuzzi 97 kg
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait une blague mais n'en vois là
et je suis croire que je que jamais des
dégâts pendant l'émission mais s'était
repris par quatre pour les 4-2 puis au
moment où on me confond guardado man et
chemise ou bisous donc non non je ne
pète pas si si vous mettez vous je
voudrais m'adresser une personne match
et croisé hier je ne connais absolument
pas qui m'a croisé dans la rue qui m'a
fait vous savez monsieur courbet j'aime
bien parce qu'avec vous j'ai
l'impression que le niveau est plus
élevé ne sait pas qu'on peut avec il ne
portait pas william leymergie à pourquoi
déjà je pense qu'en terme de caractères
en sortant des herbes sont absolument
pas du tout et maribor leur pelle il est
là 12h30 au portugal à aa et c'est pour
qu'il me réveille à 4 heures du matin
vingt quatre heures de l'après midi
donc je pense qu'on va pouvoir gérer
voilà alors moi je moi je partirai bien
écouler les mines à wisekey les garçons
je découvre alors lui aussi l'éclair au
coming
alors si on peut dire je suis désolé
mais vous avez dit récemment le roi
c'était avec cyril hanouna j'étais assis
à la place d'alsace vous avez dit que
vous partiriez bien que vous aviez envie
de faire l'amour avec un homme
enfin je sais pas un truc comme ça vous
l'avez dit si vous n'avez pas dit et
bien évidemment mais vous avez un
problème de psychologie déjà s'est pas
calmée logique alors la plus n'ont alors
pas dire qu'olivier mini sera content le
point de plus depuis des années ah oui
et on peut comprendre des mêmes passions
sûr on est beaucoup de bloquer tous les
deux et et bien je vous retiens quand
même un nom mais c'est surtout parce
qu'il est marié c'est pour ça que non
mais vous ne partez pas qu'on finisse
qu'on commette une fin cette séquence
alors vous ne verrez jamais avec avec
avec lopez et pourquoi pas noir non mais
non parce que ça ce ne serait pas vous
non pas ce que je ferais je le tri des
sinistres il vous poseraient des classes
du tour votre ville et vous repartez
avec vous si vous me le proposait elle
avec caroline et s'il est là
il a tellement mangé une voiture de
sport comme monsieur kassali j'ai un
monospace et je peux rentrer plus de
monde je fais pas le malin simplicité
c'est bon et vous pariez avec nous vous
avez dit quoi on fait moins de madame on
peut rentrer à plusieurs